hey leute herzlich willkommen zum
heutigen video heute ist ein besonderer
tag nicht weil ich zwei fahren in
folgendem video hochladen sommer war ein
andy mitarbeiten und heute geburtstag
hat nein
ihr erinnert euch vielleicht hat mir
schon mal so ein cooles asiatische
süßigkeiten wie dem machtkampf apache
bei süßigkeiten gemacht haben und heute
hatte ich schon wieder ein cooles
geschenkt bekommen betriebswirt sich was
cooles gewünscht und war läuft es wird
nichts geringeres als ein einsatz
ok und doch machen wir wird der fürther
waschmaschinen richtig coolen
verschiedene laver schwierig das ist ein
geschmack richtung aber wir haben hier
füllen verschiedene geschmacksrichtungen
was haben wir dir gerne einmal mottaki
dann haben wir apfelkuchen filmgeschmack
dann haben wir fehler eiscreme player
bieten und webshops sind eigentlich
richtig kraft weil ich habe noch nie
irgendwo zucker wasser mit geschmack und
wir haben passen dazu einfach viele
lebenswerte farben mit denen wir die
zucker hat einfallen also mit langen
reden wir beginnen einfach mit der
ersten platte leute gerade mal die
maschine angeschnitten die muss nämlich
erst mal zehn minuten ohne zucker drin
oder ohne zucker drin laufen in der
zwischenzeit bereiten mir schon die
allererste flugreise zu und zwar machen
wir apple cinema in soweto horden von
ich nehme hier
ein kurzes intro kann etwas merkt man
das wirklich zu wehr dass die maschine
sagt aber die monster zwischenfragen
damit die in kunststoffen samstag soll
dennoch transparent nicht erst mal so
lange zeit extrem hoch konzentriert roma
war ein treffen meinte wenn wir uns mit
perfekt perfekt meinte von anfang an
gewusst dass man drückt ihr dort wo das
licht mega gut ja ich noch nie
zuckerwatte mit geschmack wird nicht für
alle die sich momentan nicht
wir lassen das jetzt aus kurven heraus
gestellt
jetzt werden wir das ein und sah mit der
spitze von diesen dem fall noch mal
vorstellen weil die sehr starken aber
bei kabeln bis man das und unter sonne
statt
wir geben dem zeitraffer gesehen kann
das jetzt schon vorher ab ich hab auch
geschafft dass meine hände dabei orange
werden einfach in die mitte eine
miniaturversion von diesem jahrmarkt
eröffnet
jetzt bildet die gleiche ersten verteilt
wird
ok so etwas drehen so ein auto herum
drehen
ja ja der randvoll sind wirklich stark
eingeschneit und auch mit dem fehlen
lassen
das mit niedrig halten
oh gott oh gott glaube da der kaffee
schief weil es in der folge schmidt
du machst du mal besser weiter sagen wir
wollen beide das abziehen von gk
peters ich hab ein bisschen versagte
dass das so fest geworden
wir machen ja noch mehrere strecken aber
es war gut so dass wir das übrigens weit
öffnet ist schon drin
wir machen weiter weil mädchen
vergreifen
[Musik]
ich glaube die wird noch viel mehr
tauglich für als auch andi wagner ab
jetzt nicht mal anfang noch länger
abfinden anfang größte was die ehe von
rhett klinikum gefahren
okay dass diese richtig bruder der auf
der stadt columbus werfer
so leute dafür ist die zweite zur
quarantäne rosa ist jetzt ein bisschen
karamellisierter zucker auf grund die
soll nach weißer schokolade schmecken
tut die apple-aktie süßer als weiße
schokolade wirkt aber schmeckt schon
echternach ok schmeckst du schmeckst
rief gut nach weißer schokolade
wir machen jetzt heller ice cream wir
gehen übrigens später noch essen da
heißt es vielleicht gar nicht mal so
schlimm wenn wir uns jetzt mit
zuckerwatte die bäuche vollschlagen aber
ich denke mal ein fall werden wir auf
jeden fall noch machen und essen es ist
einfach lecker die schwarzen mischung
schreibt mir kennen die in die
kommentare wenn ihr noch dran wert weil
video auf bisher noch zu wenig
unterhaltungswert auf dem wahlzettel
hinter ubisoft aber die verkäufer nicht
machbar
die beste bisher habe ich auch gedacht
erst probieren wir machen die profis auf
jeden fall also dass wir jetzt eine
skater zuckerwatte sein sind da schmeckt
man es am wenigsten leute über hier noch
was essen heute hält es jetzt einen tag
später und mir ist aufgefallen dass sie
auf dem zeitpunkt nicht mehr weiter
gefilmt habe weil wir dann schnell und
mussten und essen gegangen sind ich
hoffe mal dass wieder gefallen es war
einfach ein bisschen herum
experimentieren und ich finde auch
irgendwie interessant so eine
zuckerwatte machine ich mein werk firma
zuckerwasser selbst gemacht wir sehen
uns dann beim nächsten mal wieder und
bis dahin